[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti à pour le sommaire ont joué
ce week-end sur les terrains de rugby
plaisir au sommet chartres à domicile et
les plaisirs oies ont perdu dans les
dernières secondes de la partie après un
scénario fou le résumé du match dans ce
magazine sport de combat lance un kick
boxeur professionnel jérôme le banner
était ce samedi à maurepas
le sportif est aujourd'hui acteur à
donner à cette occasion des conseils des
dizaines de participants plus de
renseignements suivre une autre star du
monde du sport était dans les yvelines
la semaine dernière l'ancien nageur
alain bernard est venue donner un cours
à des jeunes à poissy reportage dans ce
magazine l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 le président du
comité d'organisation tony estanguet a
annoncé la liste des 500 premières
collectivités à avoir décroché le label
la terre de jeux 2024 parmi elles 14
entités yvelinoise on retrouve notamment
saint quentin en yvelines guyancourt
plaisir est en cours
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye ou encore
croissy sur seine
ce label permettra au site de devenir
des centres de préparation jeu ils
pourront également accueillir des
délégations pendant les jeux olympiques
et paralympiques sur les périodes de
compétition on continue par du rugby
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir n'a pas réussi à s'imposer
contre chartres ce dimanche la faute à
une fin de match au scénario fou le
résumé du match des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude en montage de jus
laughren ville une deuxième mi temps de
folie au scénario cruel pour plaisir
lors de la 9e journée de fédérale 2
après un premier acte dominé par
chartres 17 à 10 les rugbymans plaisir
oies se sont ressaisis en deuxième
période devant leur public qu'ils
arrivent à inscrire deux essais dont un
à deux minutes de la fin du match pour
passer devant 24 à 17
mais en quelques minutes leurs espoirs
de victoire s'effondre chartres marque
un essai de pénalité plus arrive à
inscrire une pénalité quelques secondes
plus tard
score final 27 à 24 pour les visiteurs
et la défaite je effectivement des coups
de pieds qu'on envoie directement en
touche des choses non maîtrisée des
quelques touches aussi con conquête
qu'on n'a pas de trois ballons qui nous
manque énormément forcément à 24 partout
au look de pénalité pour gagner
effectivement monbahus il la met
ouais ça s'est joué à deux trois fait
dieu sur la fin et malheureusement ça
tourne ça tourne contre nous encore
après cette défaite plaisir se retrouve
désormais à la 10e place du classement
de fédérale 2 avec seulement deux
victoires au compteur l'équipe se
retrouve en danger pour la suite de la
saison
forcément
on va on va on va pas mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs et voilà on va être
humble encore une fois on a travaillé à
cul militer mais voilà on va tout faire
pour se maintenir encore une fois cette
année
aujourd'hui là c'est évident on est en
manque de points donc on va on va
chercher le plus de points de points
possible donc on regarde maintenant le
bloc qui est sûr le bas là où on est au
départ on cherchait bloc de médian 6e 5e
place qui est assez qui était accessible
pour se ressaisir et continuer à croire
au maintien les plaisirs ou à joueront
sur le terrain d'orléans le 8 décembre
prochain et dernier du championnat après
la fédérale 2 nous avons parlé de la
fédérale 3 verset ya perdu ce week-end
contre gretz tournan ozoir sur le score
de 32 à 27 mai au classement les versets
et son quatrième en étant promu dans ce
championnat cette saison pour nous
parler du club nous recevons sur ce
plateau pierre chevallier responsable
communication du club et le président
éric tournier bonsoir messieurs bonsoir
alors c'est une défaite logique ou pas
ce résultat de ce dimanche
sur la physionomie du match pas
forcément sur la fiche en elle-même
on va dire que c'est logique parce que
c'était un des gros prétendant un des
quatre premiers un des quatre premiers
de la de la poule à ce moment là qui
recevrait donc là on va dire que la
logique a été respectée le celui qui
recevait a eu le supplément d'âme le
supplément de mental pour pouvoir
l'emporter
ça laisse un petit goût amer ou pas
président koksal là non pas du tout
parce que on a quand même un début de
saison étonnant c'est parce qu'on avait
envisagé comme objectif on a dû prendre
avance dans notre perspective donc
c'est normal on peut pas gagner tous les
matches on savait que c'était une très
grosse équipe revenir avec un point
c'est très bien c'est une défaite contre
un adversaire direct ou pas alors
oui on a le classement vous êtes
quasiment au coude à coude mauvais mais
oui non parce que nous notre objectif au
départ de la saison c'était simplement
se maintenir il faut pas oublier qu'on
monte en fédérale 3 on connaissait un
peu notre jeu donc on ne sait pas la
situation par rapport aux équipes de
ferrals 3 maintenant c'est vrai qu'avec
se termine ce premier bloc on est
quatrième je vous cache pas qu'on voit
peut-être revoir nos objectifs et
chercher la qualification
vous avez parlé de maintien en début de
saison vous avez interviewé air est tout
à fait alors vous étiez sur une série de
quatre victoires consécutives
est-ce que ça va permettre un coup
d'arrêt justement l'équipe cette défaite
non non parce que comme le comité des
rixes et c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
logique non le dans la physionomie d'un
match comme celui là c'était on était 3e
avant cette journée là il nous
reprennent cette troisième place on
repasse on repasse 4e la logique
sportive a été a été respectée avec une
équipe très dure à manoeuvrer chez elle
ça depuis quelques depuis au moins deux
saisons en fédérale 3 c'est connu que
gto est une est une bonne équipe atone
ici bonne équipe en général une bonne
équipe principalement à domicile et le
coup d'arrêt non parce que encore une
fois en est qu'on a un peu d'avancé sur
le tableau de marche par rapport à ce
qui était promis à un promu notamment et
on a on a une semaine de trêve la
désormais et puis il reste des deux
derniers matchs de la phase aller avec
des affiches un peu différente un
déplacement à pithiviers qui est
actuellement plutôt dans le bas du
classement
et puis on finit on finit l'année 2019
avec la réception de la cbb solide
leader invaincu pour l'instant donc on a
on a deux beaux matches là de beaux
matchs pour terminer la fin de la phase
aller et je pense que dans les têtes
cette défaite qui permet quand même de
ramener un point défensif est une somme
toute une
une étape logique dans l'année de
fédérale 3 d'un montant pour vous il n'y
a pas eu de suffisance dans la
préparation ce match ah non du tout du
genre continuer à s'entraîner à
légèrement l'entraînement mais plus que
jamais justement parce que si si jamais
le club revoit un petit peu ses
objectifs justement il faut pouvoir les
assumer
on est en avance par rapport à un
objectif de maintien mais si la
qualification devient d'un objectif
seuls les quatre premiers voire les cinq
les meilleurs cinquièmes passe donc les
places les places vont être chères donc
donc tout le monde est concentré et bien
bien focus sur le sur la saison
justement l'a vu le classement vous est
quatrième actuellement vous regardez
devant ou derrière
quand je regarde toujours devant devant
donc si j'aurais pu m'en tiens regarde
doors donneront les optimistes il faut
pas oublier qu'on a une réserve qui est
quand même aujourd'hui troisième on a
une équipe iii seniors qui pour
l'instant rien moins qu il ya un bon
réservoir
on est un bon réservoir et ont fait
monter vraiment nos jeunes donc on est
sur une saison pleine au test beaucoup
de joueurs en première
beaucoup de jeunes on a aussi beaucoup
de blessés mais on a un réservoir donc
les perspectives sont très bonnes en ce
début de saison il est étonnant ou pas
selon vous pierre chevalier genou qui
connaissait le club depuis par coeur les
avait sur le papier
sur le papier il est alors d'un point de
vue extérieur il est étonnant puisque
c'est un promu qui défend crânement sa
chance dans une poule assez relevée une
poule franciliens assez relevé
finalement parce qu'il ya que trois
clubs qui ne sont pas en ile de france
d'un point de vue un terrain interne on
est dans la continuité du travail que
réalisé depuis trois saisons maintenant
qui a terminé pour l'instant en
apothéose l'année dernière avec une
saison où les seniors notamment on
termine invaincu en équipe première avec
un bobo petit trajet en une et en
réserve en phase finale et surtout on
est dans le tableau de marche de
l'aspect formation
c'est à dire que notre voeu de faire
jouer un maximum de joueurs formés au
club en équipe senior première réserve
se réalise il ya même une équipe iii
maintenant comme l'a rappelé eric qui
permet aussi à tous de jouer et
d'intégrer pas moins de 10 et de 10
juniors actuellement des juniors montant
qui joue en première et en réserve et en
équipe iii qui fait la différence
finalement ce sont les jeunes qui
intègrent ce groupe senior bb oui 12
merveille non non non je il ya un mixte
il ya un mixte mais on est on est très
surpris par nos jeunes juniors qui sont
montés cette année en senior du niveau
qu'ils auront ce qui prouve que les u18
nationaux et les cadets les 8-16
nationaux ont une grande qualité donc
finalement on est assez fiers de notre
formation parce qu on est en train
d'amener finalement tout de suite à 18
ans en équipe première
des gens qui qui honnêtement joue très
bien vous avez trois défaites
actuellement en neuf matches est-ce que
c'est trop pour espérer le top 3 top 3
ou 4 l'avenir l'avenir le dira mais
comme comme la peau est assez homogène y
la cbb qui semble être une tête devant
puisqu'il puisque actuellement invaincu
derrière les places vont être chères
mais mais on a vu notamment lorsque
lorsque les seigneurs de versailles sont
allés gagner à blois que parmi les cinq
six équipes de haut de tableau la
première moitié
les surprises étaient possibles on a
même eu lieu on voit une surprise en bas
de tableau avec auxerre qui était plutôt
habitué aux premières places qu'il a va
batailler désormais pour le maintien
donc il ya pas mal de pas mal de
surprises
certes certes trois défaites mais pour
un promu c'est finalement assez peu et
4e place c'est c'est finalement aux us
et les quatre hommes qui sont qualifiés
la fédérale 2 c'est un rêve pour
versailles on rêve on n'y pense pas
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a un groupe qui vit bien
le club vit très bien on est en train de
tout structuré que ce soit des seniors à
l'école de rugby
on a créé des centres de
perfectionnement ont fait venir des
jeunes on les forme donc il n'y a pas
que les seniors au club et aujourd'hui
les objectifs sur cette année c'est pas
la fédérale 2 donc
et si vous arrivez à vous qualifier
fédéral fier d'eux lorsque la rendre un
choix à faire avec le bureau les coaches
les joueurs et les partenaires et on
décidera tous ensemble puis à ce qu'une
ville comme versailles mérite un club en
fédérale 2 c'est un peu une arlésienne
plaisir par exemple qui ont fait du mal
et de des années ça peu l'arlésienne il
y avait au départ c'est pas forcément
dans la culture de versailles d'avoir un
club jose aux dires le gros mot semi-pro
en gros ça souvent souvent germé dans
l'est dans les têtes de différents
membres du bureau qui se sont qui se
sont succédé je crois que là maintenant
avec le bureau qui est aux manettes il
ya une certaine forme de lucidité une
certaine forme d'objectivité aussi
satisfaction comme le rappelait eric sur
l'aspect formation intégration des
jeunes dans le dans le groupe senior
maintenant si
cette mayonnaise prend si bien que l'on
peut imaginer aller un petit peu plus
haut ça se fera par une réflexion
globale avec tous les acteurs tous les
acteurs qui gravitent autour de
versailles joueurs en tête coach bureaux
partenaire puisque évidemment ça se fait
merci à tous les deux dépassé sur ce
plateau bon courage pour la suite de la
saison et surtout beaucoup de victoires
et une possible montée en fédérale 2 on
ne sait jamais on continue à part du
handball ont joué ce week-end dans le
championnat de nationale 2 féminine
après une mauvaise série de deux
défaites consécutives
montigny-le-bretonneux se reprend les
éléments tels se sont imposés sur le
terrain de patronage laïque et granville
sur le score de 23 à 19
la meilleure buteuse côté
montigny-le-bretonneux se prénomme
delgado de gracq cas avec 7 buts en 13
tirs avec cette victoire la smb handball
pointe à la 5e place à deux petits
points de la première place détenue par
two le 40eme toujours handball mais
cette fois ci en nationale 3 masculine
plaisir s'est lourdement incliné sur le
terrain de aubervilliers ce samedi 23
novembre les plus hauts rangs perdu 36 à
21 une défaite qui fait mal aux
yvelinois
les joueurs sont désormais dixièmes du
championnat sur 12 équipes engagées avec
seulement une victoire et un nul en sept
matchs depuis le début de la saison
prochaine rencontre le samedi 30 rni 30
novembre sur le terrain tu d'asnières
colombes en football ont joué à sur les
terrains de régionale 2 trappe qui a
changé d'entraîneur depuis deux matches
avec l'arrivée des chamailleries a
réussi à arracher le match nul à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de nanterre
ce dimanche score final un but partout
les trappistes pointe toujours à la 10e
place du classement espère toujours
pouvoir se maintenir en fin de saison
pour l'instant
leur bilan est compliqué ils n'ont gagné
que deux matches depuis le début de la
saison
toujours en football une rencontre
internationale s'est tenue mardi dernier
à clairefontaine dans les yvelines
l'équipe de france des moins de 20 ans
coachés par l'ancien champion du monde
bernard diomède se sont imposés 2 buts à
1 dans un match amical contre les
pays-bas
le rennais rafik gitta n'a marqué le but
de la victoire à la 81e minute
l'attaquant de l'ol amina goerich avait
ouvert le score en première période les
moins de 20 ans s'était entraîné à
croissy-sur-seine la semaine d'avant
direction à présent à maurepas l'ancien
kick boxeur professionnel français à
jérôme le banner et s
10 au gymnase de la malle me donne pour
donner un cours pendant trois heures
l'ancien sportif est aujourd'hui acteur
a rencontré des dizaines de participants
objectif transmettre le style le banner
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
un montage de jus lokeren ville le
kickboxeur jérôme le banner reçu comme
une superstar à maurepas ce samedi 23
novembre le sportif est venue donner un
cours destiné au pratiquant le sport de
combat et d'arts martiaux gymnase de la
manne me donne une première pour le club
local
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer jérôme
il ya quelques mois on a discuté et
c'est vrai qu'il était partant pour
venir rencontrer notre club et c'est
vrai qu'il apporte
il apporte beaucoup de choses et
l'apprécier rencontrer ces petits clubs
qui ressemble au club lui-même il a il a
débuté
l'ancien sportif d'un mètre
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent vingt kilos
environ a donné un cours de trois heures
objectif partagé son expérience que je
veux tu es là comme ça on peut tomber au
champ avant ses atouts un peu lents
comme ça
moi je me réjouis qu'il fasse la façon
dont moi on m'a appris moi on m'a appris
beaucoup de choses se joueront après
plusieurs formes pur style et enfin j'ai
fait mon style gerber et j'essaie de
leur inculquer ce à dire qu avec le le
bagage qu'ils ont on essaie de voir
d'autres petits horizons mais c'est la
même chose mais avec quelques quelques
différences frapper sans respect
détruire l'événement a regroupé des
dizaines de participants venus du
secteur mais également de la france et
de l'étranger
quand je souhaite aussi corbas c'est une
idole super super bowl a vraiment un
exemple à suivre donc
la quarantaine passée est toujours là
quand j'ai 54 ans doit passer un examen
sur maléfique la chance de pratiquer
avec quelqu'un d'aussi célèbre d'aussi
technique est aussi reconnue et
principalement l'humilité parce que
cette personne là il faut savoir que
c'est un exemple d'humilité
après la venue de jérôme le banner
l'école de boxe française et l'on court
voire pas réfléchit déjà à organiser
d'autres événements de ce type dans les
prochains mois
je vous propose maintenant de prendre
une profonde respiration et de vous à
détendre une journée spéciale yoga était
organisée à montils pour retenu par
quatre associations une centaine de
participants s'est rendu au complexe
sportif pierre de coubertin pour
l'occasion des images du très zen
patrick jacques de dixmude à une pause
détente en plein montigny le bretonneux
une journée consacrée au yoga était
organisée ce dimanche 24 novembre au
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin ce
rendez vous gratuit a été lancé par la
ville
nous avons commencé en 2016 à montigny
le bretonneux et nous nous l'offrons
chaque année nous essayons de le faire
avec l'os sous le haut patronage de
l'ambassade de l'inde
et c'est un moyen aussi d'offrir un
moment
bien-être anonymement tard la séance
s'est déroulée sous les yeux de quatre
associations spécialisées dans le yoga
objectif évacuer le stress à travers des
postures sportive alliant force physique
et souplesse et bien fait cette pratique
de yoga c'est une philosophie de vie et
c'est une meilleure connaissance de soi
l'événement affiché complet avant la
séance au total une centaine de
personnes s'est inscrite pour cet
événement c'était la première fois que
je faisais ça et c'est une découverte
pour moi quoi parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de une grosse détente
au niveau du corps détendu ça fait du
bien encore au corps et à l'esprit
on sent vraiment quand on a des tensions
et quand on écoute bien le dire l
intervenante
effectivement vous arrivez à vous
détendre sans pour autant avoir
d'expérience donc je pensais avec
l'expérience doit faire vraiment bien
depuis sa création ce rendez vous a
également permis de faire la promotion
du yoga dans la ville depuis la rentrée
tous les cours organisés dans la commune
affiche presque complet et vu
l'engouement suscité cette année
l'effervescence devrait continuer on va
maintenant parler de voile louis burton
originaire de rambouillet a réussi à
terminer le 11 novembre dernier la
transat jacques vabre avec son coéquiper
davy beaudart ils ont relié le havre au
brésil à bord de son bureau vallée 2 en
14 jours cinquante et une minutes et 43
secondes un temps qui leur permet de
finir en huitièmes dé la course terminée
louis burton est déjà dans son prochain
objectif le vendée globe 2020 une course
sur le sportif yves binois a de grandes
ambitions nous l'avons contacté par
téléphone
c'est sûr que ça ça reste objectif faire
mieux qu'en 2016 ça c'est sûr donc 7e
pour faire mieux qu'un top 5 c'est pas
loin et puis on finir quand il ya ont
fait que sur le vendée globe même avec
des bateaux qui sont de plus en plus
fiables malheureusement il ya entre les
casses mécaniques les classes urbaines
etc
en général la moitié qui n'existe pas à
terminer donc essayer tout tout faire
pour pas être dans cela donc beaucoup
travaillé sur la fiabilité
on continue sur la thématique de l'eau
le double médaillé olympique de natation
alain bernard était mercredi dernier à
poissy le sportif est venu donner des
conseils à des jeunes nageurs pisciacais
à la piscine mignot ces derniers sont
ressortis avec des étoiles plein les
yeux à montage de sandrine fontaine une
star de la natation à poissy alain
bernard est venu ce mercredi 20 novembre
à la piscine mignot dans le cadre du
master class le double médaillé
olympique aux jo s'est glissé dans la
peau d'un entraîneur le temps d'un après
midi
ça me plaît parce que
voilà j'ai des anecdotes aussi dans mon
passé qui m'ont permis de rencontrer des
champions je je m'en souviens ça m'a
marqué je m'en suis servi et voilà ça
peut avoir un impact sur eux que ce soit
quelque chose de cassé quantifiable dans
le sport ou dans leur vie voilà c'est
ont contribuer à leur épanouissement on
aura rempli notre mission
cette treizième dates de la tournée
française d'alain bernard était destiné
aux enfants du secteur âgés de 9 à 17
ans les jeunes sportifs ont pu se prêter
au jeu des questions réponses et nager
sous le regard de cet ancien
professionnel qui a stoppé sa carrière
en 2012 c'est très important pour moi
parce que quand même des réalisations
mondial s'est
c'est incroyable je trouve ces inédits
on pourrait dire ça comme ça
champion olympique
certes honneur pour nous on n'a jamais
vu un champion olympique comme ça en
vrai impressionnant une fois remis de
leurs émotions les jeunes et alain
bernard ont terminé la session par une
séance photo l'occasion d'immortaliser
encore un peu plus cette rencontre
inédite
on continue à parler d'alain bernard
l'ancien nageur s'est prêtée à notre
désormais traditionnel jeu des trois
questions regardez la séquence
[Musique]
j'ai commencé la natation tout d'abord
parce que mes parents souhaitaient que
je sache bien nagé c'était vraiment la
base d'être à l'aise dans l'eau être
capable de se déplacer en toute sécurité
et bien sûr j'ai enchaîné sur la
natation avec des entraînements assez
régulier j'ai rencontré mes meilleurs
amis et puis voilà la suite on la
connaît
jusqu'au au plus haut niveau
international mais à la base c'était
vraiment pour apprendre à nager c'est
une cause pour laquelle je suis très
sensible
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir c'est peut-être
pas forcément associée à une médaille du
titre ou un record c'est sur mes
derniers championnats de france où le
façon spontanée des spectateurs se sont
levés et m'ont applaudi pour me
féliciter finalement de cette carrière
qui était plus derrière moi que devant
et ça va être ça m'a beaucoup touché ça
m'a fait chaud au coeur parce que
c'était quelque chose de spontané et
c'est vraiment la première chose qui
nous attend demain
de quoi sera fait mon avenir ça je sais
pas vraiment maintenant j'essaie de vrai
pour le grand nombre fait et j'ai
vraiment fait le choix de pam ont créé
un seul endroit pour accompagner un
groupe de sportifs et de nageurs plus
spécifiquement la chance de pouvoir
aussi rayonner un peu partout en france
et porter ces messages de valeurs
d'intégration d'engagement qu'impose le
sport de haut niveau et puis on est à
l'aube des jeux olympiques de paris 2024
c'est très important de sensibiliser
l'opinion public de tout âge à la bonne
pratique le sport pour être en bonne
santé
s'épanouir on passe maintenant notre
page agenda on commence cet agenda part
du football le tirage au sort du 8e tour
de la coupe de france de football a eu
lieu la semaine dernière et versailles
qualifié après sa victoire 3 2 face à
sainte marie à la réunion a été épargné
le dernier représentant yves binois se
déplacera chez un club de nationale 3
vire ce tour est le dernier avant
l'entrée en lice des clubs de ligue 1 en
32e de finale l'année dernière
versailles s'est arrêté à ce huitième
tour de la compétition contre lens on
continue cet agenda part du rugby ans
jouera dans le championnat honneur
l'union rugby centre 78 recevra ce
dimanche à 15 heures l'europe que j fois
au stade du bout des clauses de maurepas
victoire impérative pour les saint
quentinois qui pointe actuellement dans
le top 5 du classement et qui espère le
rester si vous voulez les soutenir
l'entrée est libre
il y aura également du basket avec le
championnat de nationale 3 masculine
trappe recevra sur son terrain l'union
sportive fécampoise et deux équipes sont
au coude à coude au classement les
trappistes son 6e et leurs adversaires
5e
une victoire leur permettrait d'intégrer
le top 5 toujours en nationale 3
masculine le chesnay-versailles reçoit
ce samedi soir à 20 heures au gymnase
mont boron l'équipe de montville où
peuvent ils basket lui lcv 68 promis
cette année sera le favori de la
rencontre et qui porté par un excellent
bamba cei meilleur marqueur de nationale
3 est actuellement deuxième du
championnat montville lutte de son côté
pour le maintien on se quitte par un
dernier rendez-vous la ville de plaisir
organise sa semaine du handicap à partir
de ce lundi
au programme notamment des animations
sportives autour du handicap au palais
des sports
l'événement devrait concerner environ
600 jeunes de la commune de primaire de
primaire jusqu'au collège
on écoute l'adjoint aux sports dominique
modestes comme vous le savez
certainement il vaut mieux sensibiliser
les jeunes qui après sensibilise aussi
leurs parents alors on passe très
souvent par les jeunes notamment dans
l'éducation routière c'est la même chose
il ya certaines choses qui marchent très
bien par exemple tout ce qui est sport
sport collectif
c'était du basket avec avec des
fauteuils roulants ça a très bien marché
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 68
[Musique]